à l'école d'ingénieurs de sousse élèves
comme enseignants ont répondu présent à
l'appel du gouvernement dans sa lutte
contre le coronavirus un challenge lancé
le 16 mars dernier
concevoir une machine d'oxygénothérapie
utilisant la technique de l'impression
3d et venant en aide aux patients
atteints du coc vide
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
plusieurs volets plusieurs projets donc
que l'idée initiale c'était de concevoir
et fabriquer un respirateur en fait un
appareil d'oxygénothérapie à haut débit
qui donne de l'oxygène aux malades selon
les besoins cet appareil a déjà été
testé à l'hôpital farhat hached à sousse
dans le service de réanimation et les
résultats sont positifs dans en
parallèle nous avons travaillé aussi sur
d'autres volets notamment les masques
avec des filtres ffp2 qui permettent
donc d'avoir une protection plus forte
pour le personnel soignant qui très très
proche des des malades et on a montré
que c'était possible
donc en fait maintenant il s'agit-là de
la vente et il faut que ça continue on
voit que ce soit juste contextuel autre
ambiance mais même combat à l'institut
pasteur de tunis
en plus de sa mission de suivi
épidémiologique du virus et des tests
diagnostiques
l'équipe du professeur louzir travail
sur la recherche d'un vaccin
un projet ambitieux pour les
scientifiques du pays dont les travaux
ont posé les premières bases d'une
future vaccination il ya un groupe qui a
déjà une expertise dans le développement
de vaccins à bagdad et m
et il a commencé à travailler sur un
vaccin de type adn et qui exprime donc
une protéine du virus qui est très
probablement la cible d'une réponse
immune anticorps neutralisants c'est à
dire que si ce vaccin marche bien si la
protéine s'exprime bien si on va d'une
réponse contre cette protéine
on peut avoir de fortes chances d'être
protégé contre la réfection fin quand
l'infection par le virus mais ça
nécessite bien sûr tout un travail très
clinique mais ensuite passer à des
phases cliniques et j'avoue qu'on met
dans des étapes précoces on est encore
au début au niveau de la déconstruction
du plat smit je sais aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup d'équipés dans le monde qui
sont dans des phases beaucoup plus
avancés que nous mais on se dit on sait
jamais comment les choses évoluent on
sait jamais d'abord qu'elle serait une
efficacité de tous ces vaccins et
surtout surtout aussi on peut accéder à
ces vaccins
nous on voudrait s'inscrire aussi dans
dans la course au développement de
vaccins et on travaille de ce cette
guerre contre un ennemi invisible a
poussé médecins et ingénieurs à joindre
leurs compétences au profit de la santé
des tunisiens avec la fermeture des
frontières et l'arrêt total des
importations
il fallait agir vite et à moindre coût
lydie venu arrêtant d'être consommateurs
il faut produire un matériel
simple peu coûteux si ça ce qui est
important le rapport entre efficacité et
coût est extraordinaire pour un pays
comme la tunisie où on sait tous nous
avons des moyens qui sont limitées c'est
là l'idée que l'ingénierie le biomédical
jeunes biomédicale avec les spécialistes
les techniciens participe à élaborer un
instrument qui va aider les malades qui
ont un problème duo covit comment les
aider à passer ce cap difficile pour ne
pas arriver au stade de de ventilation
artificielle avec incubation et
séjour dans un dans une unité de soins
intensifs
le prototype a été créée grâce donc à
cet âge ils ling et elle le 3d le prix
jim brady qui a permis donc de faire ce
matériel ce matériel qui est la leur au
type effet est fin prêt pour être
utilisé la recherche la science et la
technologie au service de la santé et
des tunisiens tel est le défi du pays
pour lutter contre le coronavirus des
machines capables de trier les patients
ou encore de créer des respirateurs à
base de technologies trois dimensions la
tunisie souhaite se doter des nouvelles
technologies pour venir à bout de ce que
rona virus et protéger l'ensemble de la
population